Jon Ronson the book is called them
adventures with extremists where did you
get this idea I spent a year with an
Islamic fundamentalist leader in London
called Omar Bakri Mohamed and it was
just going to be a newspaper article
actually and he was so unlike one's
mental picture of a Muslim extremist he
was kind of buffoonish and silly and
burlesque I thought that's so
interesting he's not like he's not the
one-dimensional demon where were led to
believe
so all this other extremist would be
like that so then I spend a lot of time
with a with a clan leader who was given
his clan an image makeover he kind of
figured that the clan had a bad image so
he wanted to you know ban the n-word and
banned the robes and the hoods and the
cross burnings and and replaced those
things with personality seminars
teaching teaching there classmen to be
you know to work out whether they're
melancholic sore sanguine and so on so
again he was very unlike my mental
picture of her of a Ku Klux Klan leader
this guy he was never she you imagine me
of Woody Allen and I thought there was
an irony there so then I figured well
maybe there's a there's a whole book in
these unexpected portraits of extremist
leaders and I thought it would be funny
and and there'd be an interesting
narrative and I thought that maybe would
be an interesting way of trying to see
our world through their eyes because all
the extremists are people in the book of
people who live among us they're trying
to overthrow our way of life from within
so I thought maybe maybe the them could
be us as well as then where else did you
go before we get in it individual
stories kind of all around the world
maybe 50% of the book is set in the
States there's a couple of British
chapters but in the states who did you
visit with okay well here in DC I spent
a return with big Jim Tucker who's a
grizzled newsman who's made his life
made it his life's mission to track down
the shadowy and sinister Bilderberg
Group who he says is the group that
secretly rule in the world this is the
theme that all the extremists share
that there are these cables out there so
I have that with Jim Tucker as he
tracked down the meeting of this fabled
Bilderberg Group and and went with him
to try and to try and shimmy up the
drain pipes and get in and catch them
red-handed going about their covert
wickedness
so that was Jim in DC there was Tom Robb
the clan leader in Arkansas who's giving
his clan a positive spin then there's a
the Weaver family I spent a lot of time
with Randy Weaver and his one of his
daughters Rachel and I retell the Ruby
Ridge story in what I believe is a more
accurate way I think it was spun I think
it benefited everybody to spin the story
is as white supremacists pretty much
getting what they deserved and okay the
government made a mistake but they were
white supremacists it was basically okay
so ivory told that story and more I
think a humanist way they lasted I see
the Bohemian Grove oh yeah you see this
is could I forget that this is this is a
group again all the conspiracy theorists
said that not only is this is there this
shadowy cabal but once a year they go to
a clearing and a forest in Northern
California and undertake an owl burning
ceremony where men like Henry Kissinger
attend this bogged torchlight procession
which culminates in the human effigy
being thrown into the fiery belly of a
giant owl so I kind of figured well that
can't be true I'm gonna have to somehow
infiltrate Bohemian Grove and find out
of this is true so my plan was to was do
it was a New York thought-out plan I was
going to shimmy up a mountain and find
it you know find it amongst the redwoods
and then I was told well if I did that
I'd get myself killed and and not I
should add by the Bohemians but by the
terrain and someone told me that the way
to infiltrate Bohemian Grove is to
pretend to be a Grover to go to Eddie
Bauer and get some chinos and so you
know some cashmere sweaters and just
walk up the drive given a security guard
I ruled the world kind of wave which is
what I did and sure enough I
infiltrated the the the camp and
witnessed this owl burning suddenly
where is the but Bohemian Grove it's
halfway between Occidental and Monte Rio
which is just above Napa Valley in
Northern California and where was the Ku
Klux Klan meeting was Tom Robb that was
in Harrison Arkansas in the the Ozarks
and foothills of the Arkansas Ozarks
where was the Bilderberg meeting oh the
Caesar Park hotel and golfing Resort in
Sintra Portugal see the Bilderbergers
the conspiracy theorists always told me
always meet once a year in a five star
hotel with golfing facilities but there
they may play golf on they're there but
they're not there to play golf I was
told you spend some time with Ian
Paisley who is he in Paisley is the man
who many people say is the man who you
could pinpoint as being most responsible
for keeping the troubles in Northern
Ireland going these past 30 years he's a
fiery brimstone preacher and politician
he leads the DUP the Democratic Unionist
Party in Northern Ireland say no say no
to he's the man who says no and when the
Good Friday Agreement was deeply being
mooted around the table at stone odd
castle in Paisley showed his opposition
to it by going to Cameroon
to preach the preach preach to the
sinners that's what he did and I and I
went with him so so that was a an odd
week in Cameroon were in Paisley
basically bullied everybody to make us
like him more and when you travel with
him how many others were with you there
was those I think three of us there was
his translator Joseph his driver David
McIlvain who's kind of the Smythe's to
am Paisley's mr. burns and and me and it
was an interesting I think it's an
interesting look at how fiery leader
remains at the top of his pile it's you
know how he pulls us in offers this
affection and pushes us out again it's a
it's a it's a
as in mine play which I think of
analyzed and who is David Hickey
especially David Icke hike yeah look
like Hickey he could they could
pronounce it okay
I see ke he was at BBC Sports
Personality really was oh household name
in Britain and he announced in 1991 that
he was the son of God and this had never
happened before so became aware did he
announced this on the Terry Wogan chat
show on the BBC one day said I am the
son of God
yeah I mean business was a big splash
it's kind of like Geraldo suddenly
announcing he's the son of gods you
don't be could be have a big deal do you
know anything we don't know is it did
does that announcement coming but David
Ickes had not only about the son of gods
but the world is about to be destroyed
by a cataclysmic earthquakes and tidal
waves and floods what I thought was
interesting back in the 90s is that okay
we were amazed and laughing but a little
bit of us thought maybe here's the son
of God maybe he's right so he went on
this chat show and the whole nation
watched and and he and he made these
predictions and said that he was the son
of God and the audience was laughing
nervously in and I think the nation kind
of looked to Terry Wogan and the
presenter for guidance because part of
us thought maybe this guy is a
soothsayer and Terry Wogan just said you
know they're laughing at you they're not
laughing with you and there was a huge
sigh of relief from the nation it was
okay to laugh at this guy and when he
kind of vanished and then returned a
couple of years ago with his new theory
which is that the Bilderberg Group
exists and they're all so genetically
descended from 12 lizards cells George
Bush Soze Henry Kissinger says Kris
Kristofferson and boxcar Willie I didn't
quite understand where they fitted into
it I mean boxcar Willie is equated with
President Bush yeah David like just
people's genealogies to work out whether
or not they're genetically descended
from these malevolent lizards and what
confuses me is how he actually even
decided to do boxcar Willie's genealogy
I asked him once if he'd done Dennis he
least genealogy who is the founder
member of the Bilderberg Group and he
said no and
think it's a you haven't done his
genealogy but you don't Kris
Kristofferson genealogy the losers were
how big by the way roughly 12 foots and
when he made these presentations in the
public eye square or forum people said
yeah right they're from lizards a lot of
people agreed with the lizards some
Davidic supporters said ok I don't
necessarily agree with the lizards but I
respect his right to believe in lizards
and then he had a large anti-racist
coalition forum kind of all over the
world in America in Canada in England
who are convinced that when David Icke
said giant lizards ruled the world he
was using code and what he actually
meant was that Jews ruled the world
and David I would say no no the Oracle
said no I really do mean lizards they
say oh no no no when you say you really
mean lizards what you actually mean is
that you mean Jews so I thought this was
a very funny again burlesque way of
examining the got a burgeoning Cold War
of paranoia the crazier the extremists
get perhaps the crazier the responses
towards them that you tell us all
through the book that you at some point
are discovered in the midst of all these
people as being Jewish I was kind of out
I was outed as a Jewish if she had
training camp in South London be hard
trained not not the best place in the
world to be a statistic
oh my battery bin laden's man in Great
Britain as he used to call himself until
September the 11th I mean he did
actually pin that on himself before the
September 11th hmm
and then on September the 12th he phoned
me up and said why is everybody calling
me bin Laden's man in Great Britain I
said oh ma
anyway I've spent a year with Alma and
it culminated and him invited me to his
jihad training camp this was in about
1997 I think and it turned out to be in
a place called Crawley which is a very
incongruous location for jihad training
camp is to come a-near Gatwick Airport
so we were driven there near London yeah
near London we were driven there it was
it turned out to be a Scout hut in a
forestry Center with maybe 40 or 50
young jihad trainees beating punch bags
and so on
still having no guns but still not not
the most comfortable place to be an OMA
suddenly hushed the crowd and said look
at me with an infidel look at me with
John who is a Jew and the whole room
went I mean how did he find out did you
join well he'd know I'd never told him I
got hidden up from him he said he knew
all along he could say stood my eyes I
don't know when he discovered I was a
Jew but he it wasn't the best place to
reveal it how old were you there was
that 797 you say yeah man except how old
were you then uh I'm 34 now about 30 and
wait a minute where were you from
originally I was from Cardiff in Wales
about how far away from London is there
about 200 miles and you grew up and what
kind of a family um sort of lower middle
to middle class my dad was a wholesaler
I always thought that my father was I
always knew it was imports and exports
and I sir and as a young boy I got
really excited thinking it was you know
guns or something they turned out to be
cutlery and so yeah so he was a
wholesale member there was a social
worker now they run a bed-and-breakfast
and how long did you live him in Cardiff
17 years in fact my great-grandfather
was on his way he came from Lithuania
and he escaped her in the pogroms and he
was on his way to New York
but he ran out of money and incurred
evidence that's how I ended up being
well where'd you go after 17 years I
moved to London why it was the place to
be Cardiff was a dead cat a town and
London was London whispers London what
did you do when you got there I did it a
year at college in London and flunked
outs and then as we said England
university life mate and then what um
whether it be be be about 18 or 19 then
yeah I I moved up to Manchester in the
north of England and started writing to
little newspapers and working with pop
groups none of whom made it
in fact I played keyboards with a with a
with a man who wore a huge puppy and a
giant papier mâché head his name was
Frank Sidebottom
we once supported the teen group brass
at Wembley which was a finest moment
but we've got bottled offstage after
about 10 minutes why well we weren't
very good essentially he were a huge
papier-mache hair to me and it art like
this and we do cover versions of pop
hits very badly we really weren't all
that good I should add that I remember
that the drummer of the band said you
know you're not cut out for the pop
industry Jon you're gonna end up being
some kind of writer not that I hope not
when did you do your first serious
writing um or writing for serious money
yeah roughly the same time to subsidize
there wasn't much money in kind of
burlesque bands with a papier-mache
headed lead singer so high so I started
freelancing at the same time and and and
in fact my style of writing hasn't
really changed much that at all
sincerity there's you know a lot of
dialogue a lot of narrative quite dry
quite sunny I think I've got a bit best
epic werewolf style hasn't really
changed human human stories so how long
did you live in Manchester about seven
years so that takes you up to about 27
yeah and then I moved back to London
Manchester wasn't much this is a
wonderful town but you constantly get
robbed and so remember I was robbed four
times in a week
robbed yeah some guy would jump over my
back fence and try and steal everything
about there's nothing left to steal in
fact when I moved to London I I
everything I owned I could put in the
boot of my car because everything else
had been stolen
and that's what I did I just jumped in
the car and drove down to London
thinking you know I I don't want to get
burgled all the time is this book them
adventures with extremists is this your
first book it's the first proper book
it's it was bought by Simon & Schuster
when did you finish it I finished it and
they I think probably the winter of 2000
and it got published in England last
spring spin of 2001 and what was your
reaction in England um unbelievably good
it became an it was an instant
bestseller it stayed on the bestsellers
charts for about three months and got
wonderful reviews
and and I kind of figured that that
would be it
I sort of had a Profile in England
anyway I've been on TV and I've made TV
shows and understand your own shows yeah
what kind of shows I've done Church
those and I've presented a kind of
interest in classic show but I've made a
lot of documentaries and it was like
some of the chapters at the book started
life as documentaries a British
television so what about the American
conspiracy theories that you've written
about in here like when did you first
know that there was such a thing as the
Ku Klux Klan I'd always known about the
Klan and always been a very frightened
of them to me the iconography of robes
and hoods and burning crosses was
something I had nightmares about as a
child I guess I was comforted by the
fact that you know the Klan wouldn't
come all the way to Cardiff to you know
Lynch a Jew
and in fact there's a moment in the book
when I was at this poppy clan you know
this is the climate's trans do the image
makeover Tom Rath yeah Tom Robb doomed
to failure because America doesn't want
an upbeat happy gladden well why would
you want an upbeat happy clan so Tom's
idea to clamp to give the Klan an image
makers and be likable was doomed from
the start
but even though they've given up the
robes and the hoods they allow their the
Tom allows his members to wear them one
day a year for the annual convention and
one of the Klansmen asked me if I wanted
to try on is his hood from China's robes
I said sure so I tried them on
so interesting because you know as a
child I really did have nightmares of
robed put dice you know and and I was
having nightmares as I was leading up to
spending time with the Klan I mean
obviously I bet I'm a Jewish person I
was thinking what if the Klan kill me so
I'd have these nightmares it was
churning up on the conscious level I was
okay I was kind of brave but on the
subconscious level I was kind of churned
up for that moment I tried on the hood
and the robe
it was so do such a deed mystifying
moment it was just silly cotton you know
cut out by by the wives you know with
the eyes it was kind of silly and and
the silliness of it was charmingly
demystifying to me
are you worried at all or have you been
worried all about libel mm cuz it's all
true but has anybody questioned what's
in here any of these characters you read
about the unti Ike brigade the the David
Icke yeah I mean he doesn't like it much
he doesn't like what I've done with it
but they but the Antioch people the
people who believed that what he says
lizards he means Jews some of them got
got upset because they felt that I was
betraying them this being just as
extremist the extremists and and I got a
little bit of trouble with that but you
know we didn't talk about Nicolae
Ceausescu and that little episode yeah
that's interesting I I when I started
looking more into these secret cabal
these groups that the Bilderberg Group
who actually you know a secret cabal is
a very pejorative term for what they
actually are which is a private stroke
secret think tank men like Kissinger and
Rockefeller and Jung Lee ELISA Fiat do
get together once a year at these hotels
and talk without the media glare they
say oh the politicians who come to
Bilderberg would just grandstand if the
media was there and the conspiracy
theorists say oh well the reason why the
reason why they're there is because
they're ruling the world from there
anyway what became interesting to me
well what what is what actually is the
Bilderberg Group doing and now and I
think they're globalists their centre
left even though right-wing people do go
to it and I became fascinated with the
idea of one belief system supplanting
another because the Bilderbergers say
yes if the Ku Klux Klan think we're out
to get them and want to destroy them
it's true you know does that make them
you know you know I mean of course we
hate the clan of course we hate
Milosevic
of course we hate Karadzic and so on so
I became interested in that as a symbol
and then I discovered that Nicolae
Ceausescu's shoes and socks and ties and
shirts were being auctioned off to
international capitalists on
to nurse and I thought this would be an
interesting metaphor for the way
globalization is supplanting
isolationist belief systems do you
remember what year he was killed
assassinated 89 I think right after the
wall came down
yeah whose Ruru Ruth was this very
mysterious European businessman it may
not be his real name he was he was
enchanting he enchanted everybody some
say yeah and all the talk that these
auctions wouldn't be about Ceausescu
they'd all be about mr. Ruru who was
this tiny man in a fur silver fur coat
and the first thing he said to me was
give me a hug and he just embraced me
and said you are very handsome and wise
and then waited for me to respond so I
said you're handsome and wise to what
war was he from everywhere everywhere in
no way he bought a bunch of lists he
bought everything he's from Saudi Arabia
he's got a house in Florida
he's a mister some people say he was a
gynecologist others say he had oil
connections he was you know he was he
was like those fascinating international
businessman you meet in the lobby of
5-star hotels and strange hot countries
and he bought everything he bought every
bought it bought all of charter school
sucks all of his shows and he would wear
them he did take off his own shoes and
put on right there in those bar yeah I
did say oh you know no I am Ceausescu
why did these people let you get so
close to them I mean you travel with the
end Paisley you want spent a lot of time
with Tom he went to spend a lot of time
with Rachel Weaver the daughter of Randy
Weaver why did they let me and that how
did you get to him first oh I just throw
them up I just kind of charmed them just
call them and they all said yes everyone
said yeah anybody say no the Rockefeller
Foundation said no I I heard that they
would teach in this course on how to
make billionaires more philanthropic and
I figured that might make a good chapter
from the book particularly because the
name Rockefeller is so synonymous with
the grand conspiracy did you call the
Bohemian Grove and say I'd like to come
no no I didn't did you call the
Bilderbergers and say I'd like to come
no I when the Bilderbergers started
chasing
me through the pork should go I
telephoned the British Embassy to tell
them that this was happening I got
really frightened I was suddenly being
followed by men in dark glasses who
obviously yeah and they obviously
presumed I was a crazy extremist rather
than a chronicler of crazy extremists
and I telephoned the British Embassy
said and being followed right now by a
dark green Lancia belonging to the
Bilderberg Group
and the woman said and she said go on
that's it hang on I just heard let's
stop it's rewind I just heard you take a
breath and she said did you say the
Bilderberg Group I said yes
she said do they know you in Portugal
and I said no they said look you've got
to understand we're just add little
embassy the Bilderberg Group is much
bigger than we are which would just an
end to say their way out of our depth
what are you doing here so I said well
I'm essentially a humorous journalist
out of my depth maybe you could phone
the Bilderberg Group and explain that to
them it's just what she did and called
me back to say well I've spoken to the
Bilderberg Group and they say that
nobody's following you and how can they
call up someone who doesn't exist so I
said you know he's behind the tree that
he was this man into a crisis was poking
out staring me from behind a tree and
when I tried to explain to him that I
was just a journalist he swatted me away
he didn't want to know who I was and
that was kind of frightening the
Bilderberg Group stands for what what's
the name from often the first hotel
where they met in 1954 the Bilderberg
Hotel in the Netherlands and you say
British is actually a lord now Danny Lee
used to be him remember the House of
Commons yeah he was he was a big Labour
Chancellor of the Exchequer you end up
sitting down and talking to him about
yes yes I did he agreed in fact the
Secretary General at the Bilderberg
Group agreed to talk to me too but it
was after I published the books that was
the kind of where do they usually have
their meetings they were have in the
United States yes yes they have them all
over the world I can't remember where in
the US then how many go put it about a
hundred and twenty people how often do
they meet once here
end of May beginning of June David
Rockefeller mmm he's I think
he said he comes that for you Henry
Kissinger Segal every year any other
names we would recognize that you found
out about Clinton's Bane what tends to
happen is that they go before they
become president or prime minister and
of course again the conspiracy theorists
will say well that's because they go
there and that's where it's decided that
they will become president or prime
minister how long are their meetings
three days and then engulf on Saturday
morning now an hour Colin shows the
three groups that everybody mentions the
Bilderbergers the trilateral commission
and the Council on Foreign Relations how
come you didn't do that Trilateral
Commission and the council in
formulation because they're much more
they're much more public they didn't
have that veil of secrecy and it was the
secrecy of the Bilderberg Group that I
found most most interesting and and what
that secrecy has come to represent and
also the the conspiracy theorists even
though they linked those three groups
together they always think that the
Bilderberg Group is the is the Big
Brother and the trilateral in the CFR
the little brothers now when you travel
do you take a recorder with you
sometimes a little video camera really
yeah in fact I film by Bilderberg car
chase my wife you started I mean I
thought I was gonna die that day so I
was phoning up everybody's tell them I
loved them I kind of found it my wife
and I may never see you again
are you serious well I've never been
chased by the shadowy henchmen of the
secret had nothing to compare it to you
see when I was gonna shouted up by Aryan
Nations I could say okay you know I've
been to places like this before I've
been to the cloud it's gonna be okay but
I you know I couldn't say oh this is
like the time I was chased by the
shadowy henchmen if you know of the
secret cabal back in 86 you know I was
completely out of my depth I just didn't
add nothing to nothing to rout it how
long I've been married seven eight years
did your wife ever laugh at you when you
called and said it might be over she did
that time she said oh you're loving it
and I said I said I'm not nothing
actually you're loving it and it's only
when I got home and showed her what I'd
filmed which was you know deserted lanes
at Twilight's with cars with blacks out
windows following me everywhere I went
she actually said okay now I can see why
you were scared why did simon and
schuster by this and what would you know
what the mechanism was to get this in
front of them no I don't know just
the British publishers Picador censored
to them and this editor just clusky who
I mean I didn't know who he was at the
time but he turns out to be just the
perfect editor for the book because he
he you know he understands that it's er
it's a funny book without being a
trivial book did you change it for
America No
the odd car park was turned into a
parking lot but I'm after September the
11th I wrote her a new preface but other
than that it's identical now Big Jim
Tucker you mentioned a lot about here
you found him right here in Washington
DC but that ran the corner from Capitol
Hill what's he do he's the he's one of
the founders and editors of the
spotlight newspaper what's the spotlight
newspaper well at the time I thought it
was just a right-wing libertarian
newspaper it turns out that they have a
history of hardcore anti-semitism and
racism but they've wised up and use code
words
see sometimes 12 foot lizards do equal
Jews and and in and in the spotlights
case it's true you know they they are on
TC maps and they cloud it and for them
maybe the Bilderberg conspiracy is a
Jewish conspiracy have you been to their
office here yeah yeah big you know
they've been closed down they got into a
fight and and well they got closed down
and I phoned up kind of excited saying
that have you been closed down by
shadowy forces I mean and they were a
little reluctant to admit why they were
really closed down which was that they
got into a legal battle with another
anti-semitic nice bag fo and ended up
and ended up getting closed down
what are they still associated with the
Liberty Lobby yes I don't know how I
don't know how the spotlight exists now
maybe it's reopened under a different
name or maybe it's about to reopen you
open up a chapter 3 and you say at the
National Press Club on Pennsylvania
Avenue and Washington DC big Jim Tucker
left a coded message on the answering
machine of a friend quote mother your
dutiful son is playing kick-the-can
on Pennsylvania Avenue Tuesday morning
10:30 a.m. thank you
what was that about well Jim felt that
he could be killed by the Bilderberg
Group any day well oh if not killed by
the Bilderberg Group killed by his 60
cigarettes a day habit and emphysema so
every day
he didn't want to be found a week later
he didn't want to be after either by
shadowy forces or by his own cigarette
habit
and found a week later looking as he
said like burnt bacon how old is he
I I think's in the 70s or do you look
like yes the body of a hundred year old
man he's a big grizzled just the facts
where'd he come from what did he do
before he did this he was a he's got
something to do with the diet and
fitness magazine which is one of the
most kind of incongruous facts I've ever
heard about gym and he was a newsman I
think he did a lot of sports stuff on
some big city papers I don't know which
ones and and then he kind of got into
the whole Liberty Lobby spotlight world
and and came to believe before anybody
else did that the Bilderberg Group was
was the key they were secretly role in
the world and he he made it his life's
mission to track down and uncover the
Bilderberg Group that's why he leaves
that coded message every day on the
answer machine of a friend that you know
he could be killed anytime so he wants
to let this person know the day she
doesn't get that call is the day she
starts making inquiries did you travel
with him yeah well I was with him in DC
for a while and then I met him in
Portugal did you travel to the
Bilderberg Hotel location with him yeah
I did and we were trying to work out you
know if anybody asked questions we
decided to be travelling salesmen which
do we just did we just didn't love about
traveling salesmen and sure enough to
build a big security was on to us like
that did you dress like that yeah how
did Jim Tucker dress oh he's got a straw
boater Jim Jim Tucker's he's you know
everything about Jim Tucker is like
shining through a venetian blind you
know he's he's come please totally
satisfied now dude how honest were you
with these people when you're with her
and you when you found them situations
to be humorous did you laugh at them
there or sometimes sometimes and in fact
you know when I was younger I thought oh
if I did that they'd think I was
laughing at them and made too close up
so I tried to hide the laughter but no
I'm now I'm a little bit older I
realized that it actually was okay to
laugh and if they relieved themselves
yeah once in a while I thought I kind of
liked the people who were who was so
serious and pompous that they don't
realize they're being funny but but but
sometimes they they do think it's crazy
oh they're actually most of the people
in this book don't laugh with themselves
said oh boy when I come to think about
it how close did you get to the
Bilderberg meeting not very close but I
did get to see the owl burning ceremony
at Bohemian Grove after I was chased
away by build a big security are there
is there any connection between these
two groups other way not really there is
in the minds of the conspiracy theorists
it's all perfect in the world order but
I think in reality Bohemian Grove is
quite right wing and Bilderbergers
Center left the human growth Republic
and that's why you get Dick Cheney and
the Bush family go in and so on and
Bilderberg is much more
internationalists globalist how often do
people go to the Bohemian Grove that's
what's here for three weeks three weeks
yeah they'll stay there the whole three
ways I think quite a lot of the really
big names Patek Cheney's and the George
Bush's go for the second week apparently
the second weeks the most popular week
and the second week begins with the with
the cremation of care the whole ceremony
cremation of care they say that the
human effigy they're thrown into the
fiery belly of the owl symbolizes all
their troubles and them in the
marketplace now I've gotta say I don't
blame the conspiracy theorists for
thinking that when you know when he put
Henry Kissinger together with a baroque
you know procession culminating you know
mock human sacrifice it's kind of no
wonder you've got yourself a conspiracy
theory
who owns the Bohemian Grove the Bohemian
Club in San Francisco which I believe
was set up kind of when the railroads
came into town everyone thought there
goes the neighborhoods but how many go
there every year
Oh a lot like a thousand people at one
time yeah that's why I managed to walk
up the drive so easily and when did you
try to get what year did you try to get
in there this was is that the July 20
2011 20 first cremation of care ceremony
yeah now I snuck in with Alex Jones this
far right-wing conspiracy theorist who
believed that the cremation of care sure
proved that the secret rulers of the
world practiced human sacrifice where
did you find Alex Joe
he was in Austin Texas had actually met
him at Waco I was at Waco the remnants
of David Koresh's place with Randy
Weaver and Alex Jones was rebuilding
David Koresh's Branch Davidian Church
with money donated from his radio
listeners so that's where I met that's
why I met Alex Jones he did a good job
he he real but he rebuilt that church
and I think it's good that church is
rebuilt why because I think that the
Branch Davidians and the Weaver family
were were victims other other government
that on both occasions became slightly
out of control and messed up and did
wrong and I believe and I could be wrong
but I believed that neither the weavers
nor the Branch Davidians really were
doing anything wrong I think they were
innocent parties Alex Jones is what kind
of a guy would carry explaining he's 26
years old and looked 10 years older he
said he's a hero to the to the militias
he said he's a burgeoning new hero on
one hand he's kind of like Tex Mars you
know a popular underground radio
talk-show host but he's also much more
than somebody like Tex Mars he said he's
an activist so he rebuilt david crushers
church continue hearing infowars.com is
his website and he broadcasts said he
broke us in like 40 cities across
America I think it's called the Genesis
radio network do you ever hear him yeah
yeah I've listened he's fantastic
come on if he wasn't so crazy he'd be
the new Bill Hicks he's he's got an
amazing run bill him he was an old
comedian who died of cancer in the 90s
and again was a kind of hero to the
libertarian left Bill Hicks because he
smoked in the face of cancer and was
Fermi and but what happened with me and
Alex is that we both witnessed his owl
burning so Emily and I realized that it
was a silly grown-up frat cabin nonsense
and the only thing that shocked me was
this is you know half the President of
the United States wants to spend his
summer vacations witnessing this you
know torchlight procession which I
thought was kind of odd but Alex of
course had his own spin on it which was
that it was human sacrifice maybe that's
a real person there so I went off with
I spin which was you know kind of
moderate spin then it's not that crazy
it's understandable and Alex went back
to his people with his own incredibly
crazy spin and you know just a couple of
weeks ago and Alex Jones fan tried to
break into Bohemian Grove heavily armed
and kill everybody there because he
believed Alex Jones is spin of the of
the ow ceremony as being evidence of
human sacrifice and I remember at the
time because I'm you know Alex is an
intelligent man and I remember the time
sent him Alex you know you know that
what you're saying about Bohemian Grove
isn't true you know you're playing with
fire here and Alex said yeah I'm not
gonna tell my listeners that and it's
kind of come back to haunt him now
so underlying all this is pretty serious
theft oh yeah yeah yeah I mean alex is
kind of crazy funny and and the
adventures you know that I have in the
book uh funny you know I wanted to write
a funny book but always you know
remembering that these people are
chilling people they may be the foon's
but you know they resonate go back to
the Bohemian Grove situation in July of
2000 this event always held in the
summer and how far did you get and how
did you get there well I I agreed to
meet Alex Jones in an Occidental
California yeah Alex California in a
local motel where is accidental it's
kind of above napa valley it's pretty
it's pretty in that kind of you know
Northern Californian hippie way where if
he likes his cigarettes on the street
somebody 100 yards down the road will go
boom little annoying and Alex was
terrible at being undercover because you
know he got lost on the way to the motel
in fact it was dead of night and he's
phoning me from his cell phone saying
you know let's fog everywhere there's
there's people just people too standing
on the side of the road just staring at
me there's people just staring at me on
the side of the road got a coat hanger
from phone back and you know said pray
for me Jon pray for me so you know I
said when the minute Alex arrived in
Northern California he'd he'd entered so
you know paranoid movie in his own mind
just his first trip there mm-hmm he
thought it was late he thought he'd
enter Transylvania okay so you're mad at
the Occidental
the hotel in Occident yeah which at
night with the fog and the giant
redwoods plus our mission to go to
behavior it was kind of spooky you know
but then the fog lifted the next morning
and you know I looked at the breakfast
menu when it's all low cholesterol egg
alternatives and breakfast smoothie so
it kind of seemed less camera with you
this time yeah a little camera shooting
the stuff as you go and Alex was
shooting it too because he wanted to he
wanted to secretly film the owl ceremony
so he was filming a little documentary
about himself trying to shadow breaking
because he brought along his girlfriend
violet and his producer Mike so he came
kind of heavily armed with three three
guys how far did you get we got the
whole thing we got in we witnessed it
you got into the demon girl how just
walked up the drive waved dressed
rapidly that was very important what I
found very funny was that Alex is you
know far right-wing Texan plane talking
kind of guy but he had to pretend to be
preppy he had to pretend to be kind of
Yalie you know and and so he kind of
took off his kind of Wild West lows and
put on his chinos and you know there's
polo shirt and so on and was so nervous
about coming over his - right when and
not preppy enough that he rehearsed
preppy conversations wandering up and
down in his in his motel room practicing
how to be preppy which was kind of his
version of preppy was camp you know
slightly effeminate talking about the
dot-com business why didn't they check
you I don't know it's a mystery to me
it's so because we just walked in all
men when he got there they didn't day
his wife with him know she had to stay
behind in the motel all white men yeah
Danny Glover's bean he's the only dad
out of all the people I researched Danny
Glover's the only black man I know of
who's being it sense it's wasp you knows
it's it's it's right when white male
pretty elderly than the average age is
65 70 did anybody know or did they ever
figure out that you were there no and it
was it
we stood out like such sore thumbs
you know and did anybody else have
cameras going like you didn't know well
we I didn't have a camera and Alex's
camera was was was a secret camera I
think it was on his fake pager strapped
to his belt he had a secret camera and
the whole he filmed he managed to film
the ceremony but in his nervousness he
filmed it upside down and very wide he
never obviously he couldn't be zooming
in or anything so all the baroque
demenna kind of that big so what do you
do with that Phil put it on the web
sold it as a video and it's that film
with his commentary you know look at the
sick stuff they're doing now
is what motivated this guy a couple of
weeks ago to try and wreak havoc at the
healing because so what's your guess if
you try to get in this year and forget
him they said and you know maybe it's
yeah I didn't enjoy trespassing I mean
that's essentially what I did was
trespassing Bohemian Grove I
but that wasn't pleasurable to me I I
don't get off on the adrenaline or
anything like that but it was where the
narrative took me I was writing a book
about how the extremists see our world
and how they see our world is with these
cables in the center of it and then I
was you know I I had to end the book by
go into one of these kaval so I just had
to do it it was so what did you conclude
after you saw the Bohemian girl I think
well in terms of Bohemian Grove I
concluded that their worst crime was
being dum-dum I thought so I thought you
know these these are the men that ruled
the world yet they're doing these silly
ceremonies and and I would see photo
boards it's a beautiful place Bohemian
Grove it's it's a clearing and these
giant redwood forests absolutely
wonderful place and I would picture
myself sipping cocktails with you know
world leaders and discussing the natural
beauty I could completely see why people
want to be there but then you see the
path photos of the parties they had the
night before on the notice board
and you've got all these men these CEOs
dressed up it not only dressed up in
drag which is kind of okay but drag yeah
but kind of dressed up with a burlesque
oversized fake breasts and you know
ridiculous make
happen in a misogynist dad I thought and
so what struck me about the place is not
clearly that they really are Satanists
oh you know doing all the stuff that the
conspiracy theorists say they're doing
but that the leaders of our world seem
to be emotionally trapped in their
colleges what was your experience like
meeting Randy Weaver and Rachel Weaver
loge writes did you meet him who are all
those people
well Randy Weaver was a conspiracy
theorist who figured that the federal
government was out of control and
determined to destroy the lives of
simple people who wanted to live free so
he moved his young family up to a cabin
and Idaho he lost his job in Iowa City
and moved to Idaho and you know had some
pretty crazy beliefs I mean that was a
crazy belief although of course Ruby
Ridge is the place for those conspiracy
theories came true Randy's big mistake
was to go and visit Aryan Nations which
was the local neo-nazi hangout where is
that Coeur d'Alene just nicker d'Alene
in Idaho although it's now been
bulldozed to the ground I think they
lost a lawsuit against the Southern
Poverty Law Center and it's been
bulldoze now and I'm glad because it was
a really horrible place did you go there
Aryan Nations yeah I drove up past
Walden no Jews signs and jumps out at
the car and said hi I'm thunder and
whoever's and didn't wash with them at
all they really didn't like me but I
survived but yes Randy moved his family
up to the cabin and visited Aryan
Nations
now Randy always says always has said
that he was not a white supremacist he
was a white separatist and that may seem
like a pedantic point to people I guess
but it's not a pedantic point to to him
he doesn't feel supreme he kind of
wanted to be separate no I wouldn't have
gone to Aryan Nations and I think
separatism is a crazy belief system
nonetheless I felt utterly supportive of
the Weaver family I thought that Randy
and Rachel Weaver were really really
good
people who deserve to be left alone on
top of that mountain and Idaho and had
no intention of doing anything wrong
what year was the mayor lived in the
death
yeah the deaths were in 1991 what had
happened you see was the feds had seen
around it area nations and thought
here's a guy we can work with this is
what I presume her panties he's a
slightly crazy person who's friends with
far crazier people let's get him to be
an undercover guy that's going to be an
informant so they offered rounded this
deal and and he said no so then they
sent somebody in and asked wanted to saw
off a shotgun and Randy agreed to sawed
off the shotgun and that was an illegal
act they said okay now we're gonna send
you to jail unless you join our team and
Randy still said no he buried his head
in the sand he stayed at home with his
family and it escalated and escalated
you know Randy was pigheaded I don't
think he was utterly innocent you know
he was he was stupid and pigheaded but
it escalated and escalated in the end
some US marshals got too close to the
cabin and the dog started barking and
the dog started chasing the marshals
down the hill and Randy Weaver's little
boy chased the dog down the hill with a
gun you know I mean they they've gone
crazy in that cabin really they they fed
each other's paranoia is how long were
they in the cabin I think about eight or
nine years I mean how long were they
there though threatened this was about
18 months so it's kind of no wonder that
that they got a little bit paranoid so
when the dog ran down the hill it was
little boys named Sam Sam yeah what
happened then son chased the dog to the
bottom of the hill and then a u.s.
marshal whoa I think all the US Marshals
jumped out of the bushes and full
camouflage shot the dog and Sam said you
shot the dog you son of a [ __ ] who
killed my dog and opened fire it didn't
hit anybody and the marshals
shot back and shut his arm and then he
he shouted this boys you know his voice
hadn't broken mister boy he shouted dad
I'm coming home dad and run home to to
his father and the u.s. marshals shot
him in the back and killed him now
they got the boy's body and put him in
the shed and the next day Randy was I
sorry I left out a very important
factors that one of the u.s. marshals
was was killed in the gun battle and has
always been a debate as to whether he
was killed by this family friend Kevin
Harris or whether it was suddenly fire
how many marshals were around four or
five at the time but after this Russia
was killed 400 turned up within 24 hours
in these hostage rescue vehicles which
look like tanks and with face paint and
people from everywhere I mean it was it
was insane it was the war you know
America declared war on this family
whose son had just been killed and the
next day they'd put the boy in the in
the shed and Randy went to look at his
son's body one more time and as he
opened the door federal sniper shot
Randy in the arm and shoulder randhir
and that to the cabin and his wife Vicky
was standing in the cabin unarmed with
her holding a baby
nursing a baby and the same sniper shot
her through the head and killed her and
they pulled her in lock the door put her
under the kitchen table and with the
kids you know I mean Rachel was nine
years old and that's when the siege
began and they were shining the lights
through the windows and you know doing
the whole thing you know they would the
megaphones you know Vicki Vicki tell
Randy to pick up the phone and Randy
would shout back you know he's son of a
[ __ ] you know she's dead she shot her
the FBI say they didn't know that
Vicki Weaver was was dead did you talk
to the FBI and the Malolos I spoke to
the US Marshal says they did the chief
marshal and I mean he's vacant right
he thinks what happened up there was was
terrible I would like to have spoken to
thee to the FBI in charge of operations
up there but they wouldn't they wouldn't
talk and they've never really spoken
about it what happened to Randy Weaver
well after a week he boat Conoco Colonel
writes the I think I think Rambo was
based on boats I've been told he was a
highly decorated Green Beret and in
Vietnam he but he turned he'd become a
hero to thee to the militants now what
you've got is four hundred troops
surrounding this mountain it's it's it's
an emergency disaster area now this
mountain with with these troops and with
you know State Police FBI everybody's
there helicopters down in the roadblock
you've got the family and then the
outside world and you've got kind of
2,000 people done by the roadblock and
it's at that roadblock that the the
militia movement really began in the
United States that this became the
touchstone Timothy McVeigh visited Randy
Weaver's cabin a couple of years later
and because the government had become
just what the conspiracy theorists have
always said the government was out of
control
determined to destroy the lives of
simple people who wanted to live free
the government had fitted into that
stereotype they became the monsters that
the extremists always said that they
were how many of these kind of groups
exist in Great Britain not so many
actually um we have the National Front
you know nasty I've got we've got
particularly nasty group called combat
eighteen who were neo-nazis based on
Aryan Nations but not so much I think
that the the pressure cooker in Great
Britain is slightly less ready to blow
that it didn't seem to me to be in in
the United States for some reason of all
the things you saw and they're writing
on this book what was the what was the
funniest the lightest
it's kind of a lot of it's funny but not
much of its light I mean I did love the
moment when Alex Jones was practicing
how to be preppy so he could infiltrate
the secret place where Henry Kissinger
was room and two to attend her a baroque
towel burning certainly that that's me
was was like in the perfect storm you
know we're all the way all the all the
weather combines to make this big wave
that was like the perfect absurd moment
to me I also loved my time with the clan
because I you know I was Jewish in the
middle of the Ozark Mountains I kind of
figured I was the only Jew within
hundreds of miles but I suddenly didn't
start started not feeling so alone
because there was a clan girl wearing a
Calvin Klein t-shirt and then I looked
at the raffle stole and the first prize
in the raffle was was a Walter Matthau
video and then Tom Rob would kind of
make all this kind of nebbishy jokes I
say in the book that it was it was
surprising to find myself turning down
my Jewish character traits so as to not
alienate Oh Grand Wizard to imagine me
of Woody Allen you know so I found that
very funny I the amount of Jewishness
that the Klan didn't even realize was
was he in her presence right she also
talked about Tom Rob now what was his
actual title it kind of eliminated that
the title Grand Wizard he was a Grand
Wizard but he called himself National
Director you see he's banned the n-word
and he's he's banned hatred from the
Klan but he's also banned all the
language he's banned you know the ground
and Cooper but there was a time where he
slipped into and you pointed out in the
book where he got a little bit tight
yeah he started we did this rally in
Michigan and we they did this rally
admission and I went along to witness it
though it's funny I remember being in
Michigan and they were doing into the
Kalama doing interviews and I was with
them and the people who were
interviewing them didn't realize I was
in the Klansmen and I was kind of
desperate to tell them have another
Klansmen you know I'm a nice guy but
um they must have thought to themselves
you know who's that slightly sweet
looking English glance it would be other
guys but they did this rally and they
were put in a car in the parking lot
with I think 300 yards between the stage
and the audience so this giant parking
lot fence staff with like you know
patrolmen fencing off the entire place
so they were really marginalized and
there was like 30 people in the in the
crowd bully 80% of them protesters so
they have no really bad day the Klan and
and Tom was trying to be so upbeat and
talking to all the police and I'm going
you know hi everybody
you know we're the happy Klan because
that's what he wants to be he wants to
be the happy Klan but what he doesn't
realize is you know America doesn't want
a happy Klan he thinks if they're upbeat
and charming and don't hate people then
they'll get on Jerry Springer but of
course Jerry Springer wants the Carey
Klansmen who looks like he's in the
World Wrestling Federation
you know it's confusing the kind of
upbeat non Haiti type Klan is confusing
to people and rightly so that's not what
the Klan is about so you've got the
media who wants Tom Robb to actually be
a racist
you've got Todd Rob's own members who
really don't like you know they think
that hate is a pivotal clan activity
they want to hate people they think
what's wrong with hating people it's
okay with the Klan was supposed to hate
people and I think all that
responsibility just got to got to Tom
Rob that day in the car park in the
parking lot and he ended up calling the
protesters [ __ ] slime and it echoed
across the parking lot
[ __ ] slime [ __ ]
and he just crumpled now I think one way
of reading that is the mask slipped and
I think that's true I think the mask did
slip a little bit but I think what also
happened was that Tom had slid into
being the caricature that everybody else
wanted him to be you know I think his
image makeover his heart felt that Tom
became what the media wanted him to be
what his own members wanted it to be it
was a defeat it was it was a sad moment
in a funny and ironic kind of way how
has this book your first book changed
your life in any way it's been a success
which I'm so delighted about how made
you sell in England in England a mint of
games and smoke is the main people right
and I think the average sales were to
3,000 and 5,000 did so far sold about
30,000 inning in hardback it's just come
out in paperback in England over here I
have no idea actually how it's done but
has it changed your life and I'm
immensely proud of it I'm really proud
that I've managed to write a really good
book and I do think it's you know I'm
very pleased with the book it's well
written and it's funny and it's got you
know interesting things to say about the
relationship between our world and their
world yeah
can our viewers that hear about this
book watch any of this video is it
available and the websites or um you can
what if you could log on to my website
which is Jon Ronson calm with no H and
John J onl ons away and you can see
clips we've got the owl burning ceremony
we've we link to you can see that the
United States has never really wanted to
buy any of my documentaries although I
was told the other day that that they
might be able to sell it if they can get
wolf smell Will Smith to reavoice the
commentary so kind of figured ok what's
next what's your next book I don't know
I'm sort of slightly blocked at the
moment I'm so proud of this book that
I'm slightly I need to get it out of my
system before I can start thinking about
another one here's the cover of the book
it's about extremists adventures with
extremists those are the words of John
Ronson it's a Simon & Schuster book Jon
Ronson our guest thank you very much
thank you